(cris)
- Ça fait des mois qu'on n'avait
pas vu autant deseseses oser
dénoncer la guerre à voix haute.
De Moscou à Iekaterinbourg,ntnt-
Pétersbourg, ils ont envah
les rues des centres-villes.
En quelques
chassés ou brutalement arrêtés.
(slogans)
"Non à la guerre", ce cri
étouffé réprimé par le régime
de Vladimir Poutine depuisvrvrve
guerre que des centaines
de milliers de Russes devront
désormais mene
à l'épaule, contre leur gré.
de 14 minutes à la nation,
Vladimir Poutine a annoncé
la nouvelle, la mine basse
de procéder à une mobilisation
partielle. Je répète :
partielle", a déclaré Poutine.
c'est l'équivalent de 300 000
hommes d'un bout à l'autre
du pays, qui ont un minimum m m.
Des jeunes comme Georgie,
que vous avons joint à Moscou.
Il a déjà reçu une convocation
et s'est rendu au bureau
d'enrôlement avec son père,
tel qu'ord s s sous peine
d'amende par le ministère
un étudiant de 23 ans,
il n'a aucune expérience
en infantrie.
"Mais on m'a dit de me
présenter à l'entraînement
le 26 septembre, raconte
mes qualifications
pour m'envoyer au front
pour tuer des gens", dit-il.
Il n'a pas les moyens
de quitter la Russie
Le prix des billets pour
un aller simple en Arménie,
par exemple, a plus quetutututue
et l'Azerbaïdjan, lù
les Russes peuvent se réfugier
sans visa po
"La seule façon d'y échapper,ns
tout de suite. Il n'y a aucune
autre alternative", dit Denis
Bilunov, un opposa
et fondateur du Comité anti-
guerre
(coups de feu)
Si cette mo
historique est perçue
e e e un aveu d'échec,
une preuve de la faiblesse
c'est un Vladimir Poutine
défiant qui s'est adressé
aux Russes.iriririririririririre
notre pays et ne s'en cache même
plus", a dit Vladimir Poutine,
qui s'apprête à annexertetetetee
qu'il considérera partie
intégrante de la Russie. I I I é
territoriale du pays e
menacée, il n'hésitera pas
à utilise
à sa disposition pour protéger
R R Russie.
"Ceci n'est pas un bluff",
Mais en quoi envoyer des jeunes
sans expérience au front
changera quelque chose?
La guerre vient de passer
à une autre étape encore plus
dangereuse et imprév
qu'elle ne l'était déjà.
Ici Ta a a Alteresc